الرئيس الامريكي جوزيف بايدن حرصه هو على
التوصل الى اتفاق حول رفع سقف الدين وهو
كان يفتتح اجتماعا مع رئيس مجلس النواب
الجمهوري كبن مكارس
نريد خفض العجز واضيف انني في سنتين خفضت
العجزه الى تريليون وسبعمائه مليار دولار
واتطلع الى متابعه الامر
ابدا الحرص ذاته لكنه مثل الرئيس بايدن
اشار الى ان مطالبه تتعدى سقف الدين الى
خفض المصروفه
اعتقد اننا متفقون على تغيير الاتجاه
ومعالجه الدين الضخم ونستطيع التوصل الى
قاسم مشترك نحو اقتصاد اقوى ونعالج الدين
والاهم ان نجعل الحكومه تواجه تضخم وتخفض
الاتكالها على الصين
المطالب المتبادله بين مكارثه
اسبابها سياسيه فالرئيس الامريكي لا
يستطيع التخلي عن انجازات ادارته في شؤون
البيئه والطاقه
الناخبون الشباب يريدون تقدما في مجال
البيئه وهذا الامر الوحيد الذي انجزته
اداره بايدن ولو تم التخلي عنه سيكون
الامر كارثه للحزب الديمقراطي
اما رئيس مجلس النواب فيواجه ضغوطات كبيره
من نوابه الجمهوريين ويجازف بخساره منصبه
لو قدم تنازلات
لمكارسي هو يتوصل الى اتفاق ولكنه يخسر
تعيد اليمين في حزبه وياتي نائب ويطرح
الثقه به ويخسر منصبه
ولزياده الضغوطات اكدت وزيره الخزانه في
رساله وجهتها الى مكارثي ان بدايه شهر
يونيو هي الموعد المنتظر لتخلف الولايات
المتحده عن دفع المستحقات الماليه
وبالتالي لم تترك يلن فسحه لاطاله مهله
المفاوضات
مكارثي خرج بعد الاجتماع ليعلن للصحفيين
متابعه المفاوضات
اشعر اننا اجرينا نقاشا مثمرا وليس لدينا
اتفاق بعد قرابه نصف الامريكيين يعتبر انه
يجب رفع سقف الدين ولكن اكثر من الثلث
يعترض على ذلك والسبب هو تضخم الدين
وضروره معالجه مصروفات الدوله وهذا يدعم
موقف الجمهوريه في الغنم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات